hi I'm Kami hazat I'm Molly Collins I'm
Filipino I'm Ashley Park and I'm Kate
Walsh my name is William abadi I'm
losing lavish Camp I'm Samuel Arnold I'm
Bruno gueri and I'm Lucas Bravo with
BuzzFeed to play who's who
okay I would say Lily then I would say
yeah
Ashley who is most like their character
yeah right yeah okay that's what I
thought Lily yeah me
no you are not like your character
don't understand
she loves nature and she's an earth like
Angel I think I'm I'm I'm I've got yeah
you got you got the Elegance of the
character in real life oh we have we all
have hearts but every that's the thing
we're multifaceted that's the whole
thing you bring in peace there is a
piece of Deliverance absolutely and
there's me that I'm abusive yeah real
I agree
it's the most beautiful compliment you
play a real character on the show yes
like I never forget when I first met you
at the read through and I was blown away
by who you're so different yes
you're so sweet you know you're so
different man I'm sorry
I was gonna say Lucas Lucas yeah yeah no
he's like I think he's very similar to
his character oh no no no no I think
Samuel is the most not like it
yeah
I mean even Bruno is really not like
yeah yeah yeah
Bruno yeah totally Bruno yeah oh my God
how many times oh my God my dad in the
show too oh my God oh my God oh my God
yeah uh I have to say that I can do only
that
that's all we need of you it's all right
also can I just really quickly call out
Pierre kado oh my god oh yeah
well he gave me some cool ones yeah it
told me to to to to not step on his toes
no I'm joking
no no no he's very he's very very
supportive very supportive and uh and
caring and protective as well actually
I've gotten a lot of Life advice from
Kate yeah very much we just forgot about
the pointers guys
okay okay but I think what I think I
genuinely feel like I've talked about
life a lot with all all of these women
we like to talk about I just like to
tell people what to do more than other
people I'm kidding William
told me many things about America about
English and that's because why I speak
so good English because William is a
good teacher no but he explained me so
many things so I did I say we don't want
to Whatsapp education threat to Samurai
he always has like a positive comment
and always you know helping us helping
us navigate little things little
intricacies like yeah but I think it's
it's true for all of us we all you know
very supportive and we we all have each
other's back on the show
I have hosted oh that's true can me too
Andy Fleming or Darren Starr they've
never thrown us apart what about Ashley
Yeah Ashley Darren had get-togethers
with people and things like that I was
never invited
what are you talking about you weren't
there I literally literally walked in
and I remember it depends on what season
you know what I'm saying yeah let me put
in me I wonder why definitely I mean
yeah the last time is a long long long
long long time ago yeah like yesterday
yeah
where I can go outside to dance and say
oh go this way yeah with those people
and those people know me so you can go
it's a work like work-life balance
sure I napped one time one time in this
show and
I just like to nap yes I like to nap at
lunch time oh come on I think I think I
could do nothing I'm sorry
obviously have not I can nap like no
one's business I'll literally go cool
yeah ready to go yep yeah yeah
if I fall asleep I don't know where I am
I'm like you don't know where you are
not even the time I swear
I wish
have you how oh how do you do it also
though didn't you borrow something and
wear it to like that's actually yeah oh
Maryland's really helpful and also when
it's like yeah she is she is I guess I'm
bringing a lot of my wardrobe to set so
it's inverted but I'm giving to Gabriel
yeah I I do borrow quite a bit and then
I
[Music]
lend us anything yeah I would say though
sometimes we pick things in our fittings
I think all of us that we're like oh my
gosh I would love to wear this in real
life and then by the end of shooting a
long scene in it yeah you're like I
never want to see this outfit I don't
want to ever wear a yellow sweater in
100 degree heat for 10 scenes ever again
um that would be a betrayal yeah I don't
think any of us do that they did okay
say it oh Ashley
um
yeah yeah sorry it took me a second to
think about that one
oh what's so insane
there because she has kept so many
secrets and she has protected so many
that's not cool and you know what's fun
okay say one of the boys
dispelling a secret but really I'm not
yes that's right they don't even know I
mean
when guardian Leviosa
Emily Emily sorry that's not scripted or
like she's she's a better you know I'm
right in your day yeah thank you bro
listen the way you come to set and you
smile and you shine that's true you you
you you your levels levels you've made
my day yeah yeah so how many minutes
this month summer close second to Emily
for me that's true that's so true you
you have a constant uh shining
reassuring comforting energy on set at
all times and it's it's always the same
and it's uh it's getting emotional over
here thank you sir yeah man I'm just
gonna say I'm gonna just gonna say the
cast because I feel like we're
supporting each other anyway and we're
bright each other day I'm being very
politician
oh that's explain I'm not gonna say me
who did the boy say
s
even though I didn't say I went to life
life advice about the boys because I
would say actually I would also say
Samuel Samuel yes smile brightens any
room
[Music]
Ashley I was on the set
do you cry on the last day bro almost
yeah it was very super emotional yes
we're back I mean all of us all of us
everyone but her you're not very much I
saw it on Instagram
I love these people baby
[Music]
make sure to watch Emily in Paris only
on Netflix
[Music]